in five four three two a night wear no
drawers one you know welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
have a very special guest here two day
we have Jesse Garcia now that's how you
pronounce it guard
see ya like that got a seeya hmm so man
how you been what's up dawg chillin
yeah man resting over here from front of
West Side I completely forgot honestly
I've completely forgot he's okay man I
she text me and she goes yeah what time
you're gonna be here Mike [ __ ] that's
tonight and I was man it was a Monday
today it's my it's Monday right now
we're recording this you you're [ __ ]
busy man like you must be super super
busy especially because the whole narcos
thing um off and on - anna has its
spurts how long have you been active for
20 years god [ __ ] yeah I know I know
I started when I was three 20 [ __ ]
years man how's it be uh this is
interesting because like whenever I have
a bunch of like a couple of my actor
friends were here
they've been in the acting scene maybe
at most like 10 years right and some of
them have like this this concept where
they don't I feel like when when people
have a concept before they come to this
city or they went before they start
acting they have a specific timeline
they they think that they should pop off
right and so they kind of get
disappointed sometimes they go well I
I'm not getting these roles that other
people have but you've been doing this
for 20 years and it's and it's still a
grind oh yeah yeah I mean what your
friends are doing people who do that
they give their self a timeline is that
they're a part of it part of it I
understand that they're giving himself a
goal but they're also giving themself
limitations they're limiting themselves
yeah you know what I mean cuz you don't
like I got kind of I got kind of lucky I
mean you'll probably ask questions later
but it's not actually I don't think it's
lucky it's a little bit a little bit of
luck in there but a lot of preparation
yeah you know that I booked a movie
called quinceanera I've moved here in
December 2003 and I was in Atlanta for a
three and a half years prior but I
booked a tiny tiny tiny little indie
movie non-union I made $1,000 for a
minute and I'll never see another penny
but the movie I booked that in February
I think February of 2005 so I was here a
little over your little over a year
maybe you're in three or four months
whatever it was and that movie but
basically catapulted my way of whatever
career I have now that's crazy so when
you when you were in Atlanta was the
what the acting scene as big in Atlanta
as is now because there's so many roles
coming out of Atlanta right now ya know
they have I don't know if it's is still
the same but it was very recently that
there was more television going on in
Atlanta than there is in LA oh yeah so
when you went so after you had that
small role and then you said it
catapulted your career like in what
sense like did all these like doors open
what like was the grind a lot harder
kind of kind of so this I was a leader
this movie I was a leader this movie
called quinceanera yeah and I went to
Sundance and it won the Grand Jury Prize
and audiences like an audience a word a
little like say no like flex it was a
[ __ ] but because I was one of the leads
as I was number as mean emily rios and
Chavo Gonzalez we were the three main
leads of this movie and those so there's
kind of two like three three storylines
his storyline Emily's storyline in my
storyline and way they've all kind of
meshed together after that after it
swept all the awards and kind of like it
was right before the writer strike in
the recession and and there was there
was money around and it was still money
to be made in residuals because it was
still reruns and nothing had been
starting to stream yet like that I I was
on the radar I was on the radar for you
know the 20-something early 20-something
Latino guy I was thinner back then and
I'm much more handsome a little bit more
hair
so I was on the radar and then you know
a couple movies that I did never came
out and then the recession hit and all
the strikes hit yeah yeah and it kind of
like it kind of fell flat for a long
time so I had to I had to kind of
re-evaluate what my position in my
career was and and and started over not
completely fresh because I still had you
know whatever name value I have that had
or had at the time but I had to reassess
what I was doing as in the meaning that
I was having to start producing my own
stuff and being more proactive and kind
of not being being act proactive in the
Latino community as well but also in in
general sense and kind of the general
universal pop this way I kind of I stay
relevant and still have the ability to
tell stories when you would so did you
start creating your own content then at
that point I kind of I was I got him the
I got on board to produce a couple
movies like an ER like the throughout
the last 10 10 years or so so I've
produced a couple of movies that were
odd that I was also acting in but the
way that people are producing content
now yeah on Instagram and on YouTube I
you know I can't say that I missed that
boat because Will Smith is doing it and
killing it but he also has a production
team doing it for him oh yeah you know I
mean when we talk about Will Smith to
someone other [ __ ] like yeah he
literally joined Instagram and then he
had like 7 million followers the next
[ __ ] day the next day and then it's
not touching a camera he's not editing
his own [ __ ] he know he has gurus he has
exactly when all this stuff for him and
what's just great for them too because
they're there have one they have the
money to to experiment and do cool [ __ ]
but there's you know but they also have
Will Smith and his team and and was
literally Will Smith could just [ __ ] on
a [ __ ] you know piece of paper and
they'll call it a masterpiece right Will
Smith I'm not hatin on my fantasy for
sure yeah he has that cloud now where he
has the Midas touch so no matter what he
does he's gonna be excellent what he's
like he's really smart too because he
was really very efficient he's super
innovative and kind of like went with
the times and
you know he went into his own reckless
suva reka lucidity for that that's a
real word and kind of came out and
embraced technology you know I mean and
kind of got in the forefront of it too
it's kind of interesting to when I see
like traditional people who are in
traditional media go into this new media
type of facet right because I started in
new media originally and when I was
trying to do new media at the time this
is the time when a lot of new media
people clashed with traditional media a
lot it was it was it was [ __ ]
annoying like interesting they they
virtually hated new media like new like
new media and old media hated each other
explain so for example let's say if I
were so I had a couple of friends right
who we all came up together right we we
had this a show called just King News is
still going on to his name so they
originally when they were going to
reboot them in color they were looking
for two new Asian people and then right
so a couple these guys they play these
really funny Asian characters and you
know they had to do the whole SNL
audition where they had a different
characters different asking different
bits so they booked the role they got it
they go cool you can have this role but
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
delete your Instagram you're gonna
delete your YouTube and you have to you
have to give us all rights to all your
content so this was happening a lot mmm
so when I was starting up and there was
a lot of opportunities that were coming
happen like whatever TBS or whatever
they would hit us up they would give us
a stipulation that hey you can work with
us only if we own all your [ __ ] and you
have to delete all your other stuff
prior to from here or not you cannot
create content and so there was a huge
clash look there was it was it was so
[ __ ] annoying interesting and so what
would happen was that a lot of people in
mices were like not we're good yeah yeah
yeah yeah eventually you'll come around
and that's what happened right and so
there now there's this weird space now
where we have been in this space for 10
plus years we know how this stuff works
more and you believe better than these
people who have just come in and they
still have this position where they want
to tell us how to work it it's coming
around now but it was such a weird space
now because so when I seen old media
people now like Will Smith and everybody
using social media really well it
actually makes me happy for sure because
it bridges that gap it's like well this
is what we told you we told you if you
leveraged it it would be
so when we had these opportunities I
remember I had a conversation with a
very specific television company I was
like hey instead of telling me to delete
my [ __ ] why don't you use my platform
mm-hmm I have over a million subscribers
and very active at that point you could
just promote it's like it's free
promotion so if I'm on your show
naturally I'm gonna promote it on my
Instagram actually I'll do it on you too
sure and it was just now we're not gonna
do that we're gonna delete all your [ __ ]
Wow so it was a very weird time for that
to happen and so when when I see now
where we're like media is going it's so
interesting how everything is so digital
it's all digital
yeah and Netflix Netflix is just insane
in and of itself right like when I
remember when Netflix first came out it
was it was on DVDs and I used to rent
that [ __ ] out yeah yeah and they took
out blockbuster they took out was it
called Hollywood I should call it was
the UH the the competition to
Blockbuster and I remember I can't
[ __ ] remember they took that whole
thing out and then when it went full
digital it blew my [ __ ] mind wasn't
what was it the blockbuster had a chance
to buy my lips or something like that
yes some crazy amount of my like cheap
cheap cheap and they didn't know yeah
and that's they regret that [ __ ] know
how to for sure and there was someone
else I saw of course I said on Instagram
or something like that yeah and there's
like some of these films too like on
Netflix like I thoroughly enjoy them
it's like this is for sure because at
first when films came out I think there
was this weird feeling of like oh this
is just gonna be one of those like
straight-to-dvd films right
but there's films some of them are
really really dope yeah really [ __ ]
yeah what's that one I don't know why it
has nothing to do hydration but the oke
Oke what's it called yeah yeah okay I
was real oh okay I was straight to
Netflix right yeah and then it went the
theatres are okay I was [ __ ] at me
amazing yeah I forgot about that [ __ ]
Steven Yeun was in that um and a few
other people too I believe but yeah like
when so good like the digital space it's
it's crazy how much it has evolved like
I I still can't believe that people can
independently create films and they just
pitch it to Netflix and go hey I want to
be on your platform and they'll buy it
yeah so it's like well it depends you
know yeah
yeah I mean I'm not gonna talk business
but yeah I mean you upon a film go to
Sundance and they'll go to Sundance and
they'll see if they like yeah I mean I
even I have a have a movie that that I
produced that we're still trying to find
distribution and it's been kind of tough
because it's a little bit it's a nobody
really wants to touch it's on the
immigration stuff unless there's you
know I'm not I'm not a huge star by any
means and another letter I get who's a
much bigger star and pretty well-known I
don't know if you know who she is
um she was in the first narcos or the
narcos Columbia and she was a she's
gonna tell my stuff she's coming out
with it's gonna be all her this year but
because we don't have a lot of huge
stars in it and this is hard for those
movies a command plus the content you
know they're you know it's it's a really
great story it's really great movie but
you know there's already shot it done oh
yeah yeah that's great have you been did
you uh put in festivals uh-huh and they
really well in festivals I so legit like
I don't know how that stuff works so I
had I I did a film with a buddy of mine
called justin chon and then we we got
into Sundance mmm and then a Goldwyn
picked it up and then we got
distribution for it but I don't
understand the the process of what
happened with it right because I you
know helped write it and then I produce
it but in terms of the back end stuff
I was just hands off it's like that's
all you got I don't know the process in
what allow I don't know what people look
for you know I'm saying you know because
this film that we did was black and
white black as it was that where's it at
where can you say it's on Netflix still
okay so it's on Netflix it was like on
American Airlines and United some [ __ ]
like that and then if we did like a like
a month theater run how cool and so it's
such a weird thing like I don't know
what people look for I don't know if it
was the right time just because like the
whole Asian thing was hot and it was a
film about the LA riots weren't kind of
loosely based on that I think I heard
about this actually
I mean it was it did well like I I was I
was kind of shocked that it actually I'm
gonna see the budget but the budget was
[ __ ] micro it was Micro Micro budget
and it was all based on favors so right
buddy of mine that what did you guys do
with the money did you guys use the set
the money that you guys earned
you fund the next one or do you guys
make [ __ ] off it's your made you break
even break even and then you know the
investors made a little bit and then ran
that right you know it was a passion
project yeah I didn't really expect it
to make that much money cool but you
know the fact that it got picked up have
you ever seen what's it called
Bellflower no I never got to see it you
know talking about their okay it's dope
I can see I got it
damn you know what I I just had this
conversation with somebody where I think
I'm becoming this person now where I've
like stop consuming art and it's it's
like problematic now because why though
I don't know if it's because I became a
little jaded about just like I cuz out
so after after I got you know the film
that picked up in Sundance and
everything else and the reason why I did
that film was literally as like because
an agency wouldn't sign me as an actor
hmm so they want to just keep me in
their digital realm and so I was like if
you want something's gonna be my own
[ __ ] film [ __ ] you ya know so it did
well and then after that everybody was
knocking on my door cool didn't really
know if I want it to be an actor right
just because like the art of acting is
so I think it's something that you can't
do with like your foot half in it like
it's just so difficult right and
everybody is vying for a very specific
and there's so many talented people and
letting you do it half-assed like why
even doing it all this you're doing it
for a hobby which is kind of weird in my
personal opinion but yeah after that
happened I kind of you know the whole
auditioning phase and you get all these
callbacks and I think it's because I was
on the other side of creating a film
first before I even try to be an actor
that when I would receive these scripts
I just hated everything I read I was
like why the why the [ __ ] is this script
even like this why because you thought
the the content was stereotypical or a
lot of things like I think a lot of the
roles I think here's the weird part
about me what I started realizing
especially the roles that I was being
pushed out for this podcast is brought
to you by purple my friends the only
mattress made for my body because my
body is precious and my body is sexy and
I care about it I care about my back I
care about my sleep you know what good
sleep does for you man helps your brain
function else gets those dark circles
out your eyes helps everything that
helps your mood ever since I've owned a
purple magic I don't think I've ever
been angry
since it's impossible for me to be angry
cuz I sleep so well isn't that insane
the other day somebody slapped me on my
bum I turn around I said you're lucky
I'm a purple mattress because it puts me
in a good mood if not sir I would have
struck you down struck you down check it
out 100 night risk reef risk-free trial
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
my friends and it's backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns
you're gonna love purple and right now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just takes
brain two eight four eight eight the
only way to get this free pillow is a
text brain two eight four - eight eight
eight that's B Rai n two eight four
eight eight eight number one if it was
gonna be a stereotypical Asian roll I
didn't really fit it right specifically
because the way that I spoke the way
that I carried myself mmm number two I
just didn't want to do those type of
wounds and I think like I had like this
this push to do like indie film that I
like so much someone I was put into
auditions to do sitcoms multicam sitcoms
I just couldn't [ __ ] bide with it and
I started to realize like I don't think
like I'm an actor's actor like I want
I'm so particular and picky about what I
wanted knew and for somebody who's a
who's at that point and still is a
beggar like I can't be a chooser at that
point and so I think like just just that
and the whole schmoozing thing I [ __ ]
hated going to these like these you know
these after party these meetings and you
know I wouldn't meet people and I tell
this [ __ ] funniest story where it was
it was this specific party where
everybody was you know you kind of just
mean they chat with each other right it
was for a network it's like a network
party shut up like how I know mm-hmm
broke out clothes off socks whatever and
everybody was dressed in the [ __ ]
knives I didn't I didn't know about the
[ __ ] ran ran showed up and I think
because I was so casually dressed people
who were young actors thought I was
somebody that I was it and so just being
around these type of people made me Erte
because I'm not around people like that
normally so they would there's like
kissing my ass and I'm like I don't
think you realize I'm not an executive
I'm you like you don't you don't realize
that [ __ ] but I think being around that
but behavior also kind of deterred me
from it because I was in a space where I
could just if I wanted to create
something or if I wanted to do something
I would just do it and it would happen
but now I'm on the other side I felt
like I was begging for a role and it was
it was hard for me well I mean IIIi hear
you and I and I what I hear is the
language that you've created for that
yeah you know what I mean so you've
created you've created a story around
what you your perspective is for me it's
like when you say you're begging for
role know you're not begging yeah I mean
you're kind of you're not going into the
room begging if you are you're going
into the room begging for these
auditions and you're never gonna get a
job
yeah for sure you know what I mean you
for me it's like I changed my language
if I were you I'd think about my
language I would I would never say
begging yeah it's an opportunity it's a
a chance to show with you you're capable
of whether you're right for the part or
not it's a chance to collaborate you
know what I mean so for me it's like you
know you having you just you saying
begging and even when they get these
other young actors just looking at you
they either one that you don't know if
they recognize you they recognize you
from your social media status or from
the movie they may have seen or just
like you you're you've accomplished
something that's something a lot of a
lot of actors producers haven't quite
done yet which has gone to Sundance
which is you know distributed a film and
which has accomplished quite a bit you
know I mean so if you think of yourself
as a mirror people and other people the
mirror you are reflecting back something
that you see from yourself in the person
one whether it's a good thing or it's a
bad thing or it's envy it so it's
admiration it's all these things you
know what I mean so for me I would say
like you know think about what you're
saying and in the language that you're
using that you're not a beggar you know
yeah if you say you're bigger than
you're bigger and then you're putting
you're putting that kind of energy into
these meetings into these networking's
into all the stuff that the business you
know requires yeah and think about the
way you can spot that as positive spin
on it you know what I mean I don't mean
to therapy as you but you know I like
this because like I think maybe begging
is the wrong term I think it
more like I just um I was just on the
other side where I think like if I want
to make something happen I could and
then now there's this red tape right and
sometimes - it's is this is why I think
it was really for me to figure out
whether I was going to be an actor or
not right and when I was watching a lot
of my friends who are actors who I
really admire they didn't have this mind
state that I had and they're like how
much like you said like i'ma show you
what I have whether I'm good or not for
this role and I don't know if I don't
know what mentally I could have like
broken into that also - I don't know if
like my headspace was right for the
reason why I did something and when I
started to realize recently was that the
reason why I created that film was that
despite you know so after after I proved
my point it was like what next you know
you proved your point so well are you
still gonna continue this so you got
your foot in the door dude so what are
you gonna do with it and I didn't really
think about that well don't you think
it's you know you live your life do what
you want man but you think there's you
know you you've again you've
accomplished something that a lot of
people haven't know you know I mean you
can't you got in the door as an actor
you got in the door as a producer and
did you say you wrote it - yeah okay so
as a writer so there's three huge jobs
that you've done you know right out the
gate you know what I mean
so yeah it's almost like it's almost
kind of a responsibility to a certain
degree if you choose to have it it's
like what can I do with this
responsibility now that I have it how
can I one if you don't like doing those
things how can you help someone else who
really wants to do those things break in
you know what I mean because right for
me is like the what I hear and I could
be completely wrong yeah is that this is
centralized to you you know I mean this
is that your feelings and and your
you're pushing and pushing and then
eventually no one's gonna call you yeah
you know what I mean and the people that
admire you too are gonna hear that
you're you're me and I use talking [ __ ]
about but you what you've accomplished
you know what I mean so I mean I I mean
I'm just again I'm just saying I'm don't
mean therapy's you but what what can
what do you think you could do to to
help those do what they want to do that
you don't want to do you know I mean
that you don't know really if you don't
have an ax desire to be an actor cool
like from
he's like when I brought when I first
broke in or let me first go back let me
go way back when I decided so I was
going to school in Nebraska I was a
college knows in college I was a
cheerleader in college and this girl in
one of my classes the short story is she
convinced me to move to Atlanta Georgia
with her I just study acting at the
second class called well what films with
this guy named Jetson von who's a
producer and is a longtime actor and
he's a back in the day he was a very he
worked a lot as a character actor a
really really really great teacher kind
of given the foundation but as in my
road trip from Nebraska to Atlanta which
we drove like 16 or 17 hours straight
I I don't know why but and and I didn't
really know the politics of Latinos in
industry or people of color or or the
diversity I just knew that I wanted to
so I actually had this conversation with
myself on the drive down it's like I
want to get to a place in my career
where I can help open the doors to other
people especially Latino but people of
color people who want the opportunity
this honestly it doesn't really matter
like if as long as they're right for the
role right for the par-4 cast crew
whatever that they want to do something
I want to get to a part point in my
career where I can go I can get help you
get that opportunity you know I mean so
it's and I'm like buy by any means I
don't I'm not no one powerful in the
industry but I have I've been able to do
that I've been able to go how long man
this is this you should talk to this
person about this role I think he or she
would be really great and they in the
book and a role I'm like they have you
know either it's done really great for
their career or they've done something
really great and and it's you know it's
been another she's my stepping-stone you
mean
so I guess having said all that is that
I feel like you know especially people
of color in an industry that's
diversifying now that it's been kind of
tough over the years and it's still a
little bit tough and it's still kind of
like we're trying to make sure that
we're not getting pigeon-holed and
stereotyped and getting
a proper exposure yeah you know what I
mean all these things it's like I I feel
like I feel like and I mean again my any
means I'm not telling you what to do and
you gotta say I like this live your life
but I feel like you've you've created an
amazing opportunity for you and people
around you it doesn't have to be the
Asian culture you to help those who have
a have a desire to be an actor or be a
producer or a Content writer or
something like that because you've
you've created something right you've
created a world that you have a platform
now that you can you can help people and
I'm sure you're doing it already yeah
you know what I mean
but again for me it's like it's changing
the language how can i how can I change
my language to make sure that I'm
uplifting others as well as myself you
know it means I don't want to be writing
my own story saying that I'm I'm I'm I
am a bit jaded as well but I'm trying to
write my story that I'm not that I'm
trying to help other people even it's
not myself I mean I 100% agree I think
it's just um I don't think anybody
prepared me for what was good what this
is for sure like yeah on this other side
mm-hmm even the friends who are actors
right now they don't have like your
wisdom you know I'm like hearing this
from you it feels really good because
like I think it is true that that that
language like it's very negative like
the way I think about it right it was a
very great opportunity and when I was
living it it felt great you know it felt
awesome that I could create something
that was from my story and you know the
person who wrote a majority of this was
this guy justin chon and justin chon
[ __ ] killed that there was his baby
project worked on it together and you
know I I think like the motivation was
kind of rooted in in in a very spiteful
way hmm and so like I don't think I
thought about the positive aspect of
what could have happened after versus
just making this film
you [ __ ] recognize me [ __ ] that [ __ ]
out right and so now it's like I guess
sometimes like I think the reason why I
want to create like I still want to
create like films or I continue to write
is because a lot of the stuff that yeah
like I mean there's films like crazy
rich Asians or whatever but that doesn't
represent my life as an asian-american
and represent my story and it's it's you
know it's very small it's like a small
scope of what people share agent
American experience sure when we did
this film guk it was about an Asian kid
like me sure yeah I mean they grew up in
Sacramento California grew up in a
predominantly black area and you know it
was very multicultural and it was you
know I wanted to do out things outside
of what people told me that I could be
right and so sometimes when I watch see
I don't even know this is a positive
thing it's like dude like I I want to do
better yeah I mean it's fine like I want
to do better than what's what's what's
out there and it's like this is the only
content that people or if sometimes I
feel like people say that this is the
Asian content that Hollywood will take
or I'm like there's more than this sure
let me show you what there is sure so I
don't know like I um I don't really know
what my real motivations stay in this
industry is and like this podcast was
literally I started this as a way just
to help people you know and so that that
in and of itself is great well here's a
couple things that I just thought of is
that one I had to learn it too you know
I mean so quinceanera it's about about
this girl her quinceanera is a 15th yeah
birthday right over Latino it's kind of
like celebration becoming a woman she
gets pregnant right before her
quinceanera and she's the pastor's
daughter and he kicks her out of the
house kind of shamed the family I'm her
gay cousin who also grew up my dad
disowned me and we go live with our
great-great-great-great uncle right
great-great-great-great uncle one of the
there's a lot of grades in there so we
go live with him and we kind of make
this makeshift family like he accepts us
for who we are and doesn't like and
there's he's got his own story what I
didn't realize and I was it was a
learning process for me too is that when
and yes is that this might be a relative
to you to relevant is that when you do a
story or you're part of a story or
movement with social relevancy you now
have a responsibility to help carry that
story meaning that because I played a
gay character and in this movie I didn't
really realize that I was try
then became a voice for the voiceless
right and it's in a certain respective
that at the amount of especially young
gay latino men would come like email me
or find me on by that time at the time
was my space that was transition
Facebook right so but MySpace and
Facebook but they would email me and and
a couple will really kind of stuck out
one in particulars that this kid said I
went and watched a movie and I was at a
point in my life where I didn't know if
I was gonna make it and he was and he
was thank you
I realized I'm not the only one you know
I mean so like even watching you so for
me he's like [ __ ] was this but this is
this kid gonna kill himself
yeah right until he saw this movie and
it became like I showed him that those
that he's not alone you know what I mean
so movie even movies like yours that it
shows people that you know there's a you
know people of all kinds of backgrounds
of status and and monetary background
and all this stuff yeah what I also say
is like when people OFF often ask me for
the past month or whatever has been for
the interviews of narcos is that Seco
the the main question is one of the big
questions is that don't you think that
the show like this kind of perpetuates
the stereotype of Mexicans Latinos as
cartel as gang as criminals and stuff
like that I go well it's one it's it's
it's entertainment and for me the
biggest thing apart it is like take the
[ __ ] win right this is a win just
like crazy rich Asians it's just a win
it's a massive [ __ ] win yeah it is a
win like this
narcos is like last last season I don't
know what it is a season now but it was
a fifth most watched TV show in the
world that's [ __ ] crazy
unreal yeah so the amount of eyes that
we had on this that we have on us now
even even with gente fide that's out on
Netflix it just came out this past week
the amount of eyes that are on these two
shows and there's a couple other shows
out there too
the handful of the shows right now
actually that let's just stick with the
narcos is that each one of us no matter
how big our characters are that we have
a lot of eyes on us now and that when
people are looking forward to seeing
what we're doing next and what we did in
the past right
so for me it's like okay if you feel
like if you feel like ragging on the
show and going like oh you're
perpetuating a stereotype of mecha
Latinos as being criminals and
gangbangers and drug dealers and all
this things like okay you're allowed to
think that you're too free free we'll
see what you want or you can think of
this as a win as that this is a supply
and demand and the public demands has a
demand for this kind of content again
the same thing with the Asian culture
crazy rich Asians massive hit massive
massive hit even parasite it was I don't
know it wasn't far as box office but it
was very critically acclaimed and people
know about it yeah another massive win
you know what I mean
fresh off the boat massive win and a lot
of these shows they're just massive
massive wins where it shows ok gives us
another chance to produce and create
content that is in what your perspective
is what my perspective is right yeah I'm
from Wyoming I'm like this kid from the
country I have a very very neutral
accent people think now people think I
have a California accent I don't know
what I've changes all the time but you
know we have our own stories you know
they're mean I'm not I I am kind of
urban but I'm not from LA I I don't have
I've been here for 18 years or something
like that 17 years but I don't have that
as part of my root culture you know what
I mean I didn't grow up with a lot of
Mexican culture in my household so I
kind of grew up vanilla American you
know to me and I grew up in a very small
town in the middle of nowhere Wyoming
about 800 people I think was a
population at the time a mess that the
peak population tiny tiny town which is
about this population is building
so I I had to learn a bunch of stuff you
know what I mean so that I have a
completely different story than someone
from LA would have that they grew up
either you know in San Bernardino or
East LA or Santa Monica or Venice it's a
different story you know I mean so
there's that these each one of these
stories allows us to have a big win to
produce and create other stories that
that you might find that your story you
know the main so when I see something
happen I see another a show that's you
know I may not particularly like I will
support it and this could this goes onto
something else that you said as well is
that you don't particularly relate to
the to the crazier occasions because
that's not it's not my story it's not
your story right so that's what it's
it's okay but it's important to support
it and because I think the Asian
cultures and the Latino cultures have a
similarity in a way that Latinos are
there we self segregate right Mexican
Colombian yeah Porto Rican Dominican all
of them like there's so many different
let Latin Latin X cultures that we self
segregate so when we see like a fun of
my team Porto Rican sees a Mexican film
or Mexican shows like and but the that's
Mexican show it doesn't relate to me
instead of going like you know what
let's support that so that we can do you
can show that there's more support and
the same thing with the Asian cultures
that on the Asian cultures are actually
doing really well about supporting
content there was there was I mean
there's always a few things here and
there and sure said it too when when
when crazy rich Asians came out like
people were asked me did you go watch
the films like I did but I bought four
tickets yeah I'll watch it later right
in I got a little bit of flack for it
they're like what you don't want to
support no I supported it with my
dollars mmm I I don't like rom-coms so
it's not my thing
copy so but I'll support it with my
dollars because I understand how
important it is right and there was this
it's like I really dislike it now where
it's just sometimes where I would see
things on Twitter where they would they
would have these Asian rules right and
it's like well how come they didn't cast
this this Japanese American for this
korean-american roles like you know what
as of right now just take the [ __ ]
wind ooh yeah
when these bigger roles happen then we
could talk our [ __ ] later right it's
different like if you cast a white guy
to play it play Mexican or anything like
it's different the debt and you know we
but we all get that you know maybe like
some white person would come in and yeah
do a role that's really not white
yeah out of all the talent that's out
there you had to pick a white person I
know you know I mean and it sucks so I
think like you know just saying just you
know attach to that like when I see just
like these Asian faces and they do a
great job of it it's like these small
little differences right now and don't
matter to me
mm-hmm psyche just take the win and then
we'll move on then we'll create things
yeah so it's like when these things
happen like for example crazy rich asian
does well it only benefits me sure you
know yeah only benefits me to support it
yeah and then later on I can if I have a
very particular story that I want to
tell it's up to me to tell it now I just
did a Q&A a live Q&A of this at a
university recently and then there was
this young girl who asked she goes do
you feel like it's like for me as
somebody who's korean-american do you do
you do I find issue with a lot of Asian
American celebrities not so she's an
Indian she's an Indian American girl
where they don't where I feel a lot of
the times like Indian Americans are
excluded in a lot of Asian things right
so like I feel like we need like people
like you to speak up for us and so my
response to her was like I understand
how you feel but I was like my issue
with that and why it's problematic and
the and it was just like Asian American
people just like Hollywood in general
she doesn't I want Hollywood to
represent me I was like okay
well let me just put this to you in your
perspective or my perspective it's it's
always odd for me when I hear somebody
say Hollywood should make a film about
let's say in her case in Indian American
film right and I'm like why and the
reason why I say why is not because it
shouldn't be there is say why do you
want somebody who knows nothing about
your culture and your people to create a
film about it look for people in your
community that are filmmakers that are
great actors to create that film because
they're gonna take your story and
they're gonna slaughter it mm-hmm cuz
they don't know what it's like and so
that's why I took issue with this like
you don't I think you're you're kind of
attacking the wrong people here right
you know I get the support in the right
way because
the worst thing that happen ever is for
you to have like another approved
situation right like this in terms of
proofing where people really mad about
how I was a Franco's errand he does like
the boys for him said about that you
know times have changed now sure nothing
against the guy but it's you know it
when you when you tried to put your
story in the hands of somebody else who
hasn't walked in your shoes it's always
gonna be destroyed you know there's
there's a certain level of personal
responsibility that I want people to an
attempt to put on themselves it's like
oh I got this story how come I keep
yelling at somebody else to tell my
story for me they're not gonna get it
right you know right but for me to it's
like when people complain about their
not yeah this is such a touchy one and I
don't know if I should talk about it
that you say there's not enough
diversity and in in TV and film right
and one it's it's part of it as a
responsibility of the studios and the
people with the money people to hire
people of color for for writing staff
for producing for directing and getting
all that stuff but for people who
complain that there's no content like
who my my thing is like why aren't you
creating it I got a problem with people
who [ __ ] and complain and and and say
that there's problems yet don't offer
solutions you know what I mean
agree I stopped so and on Facebook I can
start a fire very very easily on
Facebook very easy to start fire but
it's only within my friends group so it
doesn't really benefit anybody it's just
it's just starting a fire you know for
the sake of starting a fire and I used
to post a lot about about not the you
know either an audition I went for or
there are some like the one of my
favorite ones were like Latino or looks
like Latino oh my just say you want a
[ __ ] white guy that
just say that that I've it I stop
complaining about that stuff on Facebook
and started having I started creating
solutions right because it doesn't work
it doesn't nothing that it doesn't do
anything to create a fire to create a
fire right unless you could do it unless
you're working actively working on
solutions writing producing and
directing your own material what you're
doing great job it's it's you know it's
only perpetuating the bitchiness and and
it doesn't do any good for anybody and
again it's your it creates a language of
thing your own your own self you're
writing a story that isn't isn't
producing any growth within yourself
especially but within the community you
know what I mean and it's important for
other communities to support each other
like I'm not really sure the amount of
Latinos that went and watched even in
black folks that went watched crazy rich
Asians but I'm pretty sure it's a good
amount yeah you know what I mean I saw
it in the theaters I thought I loved it
and it's again it's not my eye I was
very entertained I don't have to be I
don't have to necessarily relate to it
to be entertained I relate to the love
story I relate to the it was pretty
funny know I thought was really fun I
don't have you seen it I did see it all
right I didn't like it like it because
I'm not a rom-com guy though okay it's
just a genre that already that stops me
liking Picasso I think like there's a
challenge I would challenge you to do
your version of a rom-com that that
would entertain you alright interesting
so you do your version because there's
maybe a little bit darker maybe it's a
maybe it's a horror maybe it's whatever
it is it's sort of if you missed it
because I literally like a year ago I
started a script of a really ridiculous
rom-com because of that very reason is
yeah I want to see I want I want a
little more realism to it
sure so it's like I could see that yeah
unless bubblegum lets popcorn and kind
of like whatever it is whatever that so
what version of a rom-com what have you
seen that you go okay I really dig this
the rom-com that i like if I'm coming to
mind at 500 days of summer that's wrong
come right sure I thought I was great
yeah other than she was fantastic so
that was like probably the last one that
I really really
I yeah stuff like I don't know if
Emily's Amelie you think Emily is not
really rom-com me that's been a while
since I've seen it yeah a lot of French
movies ER and foreign films were really
good about it they do a different take
on it and that's why when it's so
interesting when parasite came out and
you know everybody was so happy like
Paul you know has been one of my
favorite directors for the longest yeah
mine too and so what you know when
people are like oh like there's like
these new it's like he's got a new
direct now he's been on the he's been in
the game for a long yeah like South
Korean like cinema has been popping for
me quite a while so it was interesting
it's like sometimes I always tell people
like just because you haven't been
introduced to it doesn't mean that it's
new yeah it's like that's the world that
you were living in and it was it was it
was nice to see it though I was like wow
like people actually recognized him as a
legit director sure giving him like
funny you watch this movie go why didn't
I think of that because it's so it's so
simple
yeah you know what I mean and it's it
and it's not it's not overly complex
it's like it's it's actually a very
simple movie yeah you know what I mean
it's just the clash of two worlds and
and you know the the the I don't know I
think I'm assuming everyone's seen it by
now but the third is the third storyline
of the dude and and the basement you
know I mean the basement life and how it
switches it's just like how why haven't
you thought about that before yeah I
mean that's what I realize is those are
the great ideas when you look at a film
and you go [ __ ] I should have thought
about that right yeah that's like the
sign of a really really actor film cuz
when I when I was watching that film to
was just like I was kind of worried that
people wouldn't understand there's a lot
of weird Korean nuance in England like
Korean humor is very particularly liked
so I was kind of you Korean what's your
background
I'm South Korean okay so I was kind of
surprised that people were picking up a
somewhat like these weird Korean humor
stuff it's lightweight slapstick II so
the reason why I like Paul Geno's films
a lot is because no matter how serious
his films are I'm gonna yeah and so
that's that's like a lot of the stuff
that I write like because it breaks up
the the Menasha script so that that that
that hit of humor I was surprised that
people enjoyed that a lot cuz it's a
very very Korean film did you watch in
the theaters yeah for sure I had to it
was it was awesome and I night now
when I when I watch a film but I started
to realize that I stopped doing was I
stopped watching too much trailers and I
don't read about film anymore yeah I go
in and I try to appreciate for what the
director the writer wants you to
appreciate it for yeah so I think a lot
of the times too like before what I was
doing is because they're trying to sell
film so much now that they give too much
away in the trailer like I've seen the
whole plot damn trailer yeah so now
before I read a rotten tomato thing
before I read any type of review I go in
and I watch the film and I see what it
is and I'll watch it again to see what I
can what I disliked were like about it
but first I just watch it just to watch
it yeah cuz I think like it just kind of
creates like this negative relationship
with the film when the first thing that
you do is you write a review about it
yeah so I get really shocked especially
at Sundance when they watch scoop and
then an hour later that was a written
review I was like how the [ __ ] is that
possible there's no [ __ ] way no cuz
they speed watches I'll watch that first
15 minutes or some sort of the way they
do it it's it's it's terrible like even
to go by when the buyers there they're
watching several like 10 15 movies a day
when is it virtually impossible watch
the entire movie yeah they'll watch a
little snippet of it they go okay this
is something we should look at and yeah
and they'll do word-of-mouth or whatever
it is it was so weird cuz like I like
how I thought about and then the reason
why I kind of and I'm glad I went
through this experience is because it's
like [ __ ] like you don't see like this
this [ __ ] was a low-budget
black-and-white film yeah I'm gonna go
for [ __ ] color you know and then we
put all this time to make this one film
and then you judged it in a matter of 15
minutes yeah it's like [ __ ] man yeah and
there's a lot of power in your reviews
yeah and you know a lot of it was
positive but there was a few things that
bothered me and it was like you didn't
watch this I don't read reviews man yeah
that was the first that's the first
thing I hadn't learned to cuz I just
wanted to see what people thought about
it and there were certain things that
bothered me so much like I remember this
one review where this where he wrote
specifically about because it's it's
it's la is such a melting pot of
different cultures and we did a weak
retried to be as true as possible to
that right so we had a scene where
Justin gets beat up by like a bunch of
cholos right but I'm [ __ ] blanking on
his name but an amazing actor right but
this
a life that he's about this is this is
who he was before prior to he became an
actor and one of the reviews wrote that
is like his character was inauthentic
I'm like wait the Chola yeah I was like
that's funny
is he a well-known actor yes well what
everyone's not not know LG is it No oh
sure but I was I was that [ __ ] bothered
me and I'm like how the [ __ ] and I
looked it was a white guy I was like how
would you know you're not even from LA
it's like you don't understand like the
East LA Mexican people so how would you
[ __ ] know like if that's if there's
an authentic an authentic part to it or
not no that's it strolling dude she hits
me I was like oh I shouldn't have read
the [ __ ] it bothered me I don't read
[ __ ] I didn't read it I had to read one
review on my movie called collisions
this I didn't read not one of them at
all no I don't know with some really
terrible ones I saw some really good
ones and it's it's you know it's it's
not a perfect movie by any means but
it's got a lot of hearts and a lot of
people liked it
Cesar Garcia let me see oh yeah
yeah he's great yeah he's great amazing
he's a sweetheart of a guy yeah I know
that guy he's amazing yeah that's great
and I was like yeah he's done big parts
and big movies - yeah yeah it's like
mean everything I've seen it and
everything so I was like kind of shocked
I was like oh it's weird like I I guess
you can't you can't let that get to you
man like it's is we're like YouTube
comments don't bother me Twitter
comments that but I think when I see
somebody who's supposed to be of
somebody who's at a higher caliber where
they're supposed to give a [ __ ] right
right and they have a lot of power in
that review just I don't know [ __ ] break
your kneecaps really did I'm like damn
dude that was like that first thing of
like oh this is a different space like
yeah the people's reviews about things
actually carry weight and how I feel
about and I had to learn early on in
this space that I had to not care and
then I thought that I had it down and
then when I read it I mean it's like
these some of the biggest movies man I'm
gonna blink on a bunch of them
I think even Ghostbusters got like a
terrible review like right out the gate
and I oh really
there was like iconic movies like that
that got terrible terrible reviews by
early early critics and in a bit super
well then they did [ __ ] there they're
iconic movies yeah I mean even even like
you know not all Will Smith's movies do
like our critically acclaimed after
earth but I thought it was cool like
after earth why not I like after earth
was hard for me to watch like I can
watch just about everything you know I
can watch just about everything there's
some movies that are really hard to
watch but I can watch a lot of stuff
that's one of him and Jaden right
that's him yeah yeah it was a it just
didn't it missed the mark for me like I
tried well I actually fell asleep in it
Oh funny huh and it was only like an
hour and 20 minutes I fell asleep in the
film I was like holy [ __ ] and I could
generally watch any one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies of all time is actually
nacho libre funny yeah that is one of my
favorite [ __ ] yeah there's like it's
like a 50 people [ __ ] hate it or they
really think it's fun yeah yeah I mean
like and so when I watched after Earth I
was like damn I never thought that I
would have fallen asleep in a movie
that's barely an hour long like I
thought that movie [ __ ] sofa name
there was I'm sure there's a handful of
movies but I still like you know I find
enjoyment out of them and it's still at
the end of the day I think it still made
money overseas is still it sure they
still made money we had I mean there are
tons of examples of movies that have
terrible reviews that oh there's bad
films that I that I like I watch any
Fast and Furious that comes out I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah watching have you seen
any trailer for the new Fast 9 it's so
ridiculous I will be there I remember
when I am jumping a [ __ ] to cross
mountains and stuff like get the [ __ ]
out of here
it was I forgot who what I forgot which
Fast and Furious was but some advocate
it was Dom's right he flew through the
window and in the scene to another
building it's like another but it was no
it was through a tank and he flew out
and he flew into a car and then he was
unscathed and then his shirt was so
branded you could still see the creases
in it yo come on yeah
the movie at this point I think they
know yeah it's so [ __ ] funny well it
went from like real like yeah fast and
furious one two like fast and furious
seven eight nine ten that are just
absolutely ridiculous but you can't not
watch I heard the when the second film
came out because the second film was
super Indy looking I heard like they
didn't have funding for it and then no
interesting the Tokyo Drift one and then
that caused another big spike or a big
interest and it's the Tokyo Drift they
wondered yeah can the Tokyo Drift one is
completely different from the rest of
the franchise yeah so that one was I'm
not sure if it was done independently or
not but it didn't they couldn't get
enough money for our scene but then
after that one came out once again
people thought it was gonna be trash but
people loved it I loved it as a kid I
did too yeah I did too
I love that [ __ ] so fun yeah man I'm
kind of surprised to like how that's why
I stopped reading a lot of reviews and I
just watched films now like yeah I don't
care oh I don't touch it like even like
Rotten Tomatoes to fight that if it sky
like this you're like negative Tomatoes
I'm like I'm still gonna go see what I'm
gonna go because I enjoy and I think
it's um and I and TVs are pretty
expensive relatively these days anyway
so I bought the biggest TV I could at
the time it's like just recently and
I've been I found what to Costco and saw
one of those bigger I was kind of mad at
myself a little [ __ ] you up dude no [ __ ]
you but it was still like an 86 inch TV
for like 1,700 bucks was analogies you
like yes to the theater experience
there's nothing there's nothing that
matches it you can watch and you can
have your surround sound at home and but
there's nothing that matches going to
the theater and watching it can't
replace this there's a lot of films too
that I know like if I could tell like
I'm not gonna enjoyed that much like
I'll wait to watch it at home
but there are certain films that I have
to watch in theatres and if I don't I'm
gonna regret it for the rest well I
think too like if it's like a big let's
just say like the Avengers movies where
they're you know the CGI and the sound
design is huge and movies a fast move
you kind of have to watch those in the
theater you can enjoy them at home too
and you get so if you have a nice system
you can still get a decent amount of it
but it's not the same yeah you got to
experience the 3d effect of surround
sound again I just I'm so it's crazy how
fast technology is moving now to share
and when I was also at this College
thing I I think one of the one of the
things I wanted these kids to know just
because of there's this excuse that it's
like I well I don't have enough money to
make a film it's like you had a [ __ ]
camera on you all the time of the time
yeah I lit like 10 years ago
the you would not be able to shoot
something at 24 frames a second 4k and a
flat log profile off of your phone you
have a camera on you yeah all the time
yeah and it's so weird when people say
that like I can't create content it's
like yo right here yeah you have it on
you if I wanted to and I need to say I
need to get expensive camera yo your
your phone just cost you 1200 there
right now a hundred percent and it's
weird when I hear that from a lot of
like younger people like it's like yo
man you you have the opportunity and I
think a lot of people are just they like
the excuses and they could because they
could always just fall back on it you
know it's like well I would have done
that but but instead it's like you know
when you fail and let's say you fail at
something like you try you always get a
little bit better after her and I
thought that fear of failure is so odd
to me and I had to realize about myself
that I think I don't know what it was
like growing up me and I'm an immigrant
you know my parents struggle to grow up
really poor whatever that is I I'm not
scared of failure sure like it's okay to
feel like it's almost like a part of the
process is like I'm probably gonna fail
at this but well if you're not failing
if you're not failing on a consistent
basis you're not taking enough risks no
100% yeah and I it's it's weird cuz I
just want I guess I would like some of
the people in this audience that listen
to this and I'm gonna say it's like a
majority then but there's a good handful
where they kind of see they probably see
what you have to you know as much as a
successful actor but they're like I
probably won't make him they won't even
try but I gotta you [ __ ] know home
see but I you know I I mean
you probably have the same insecurity
sometimes too and you go man I'm not
yeah if I had this in the snis but like
but I kind of did already have it you
know you know I mean I'll do that when I
have this or if I you know if I had this
certain things like well my buddy has
that why can't we all do something
together um so there's really there
really isn't an excuse I mean you can
you can have you so I got the chance to
work with Ted Melfi who's the director
of this movie called the Starling it's a
Melissa McCarthy maybe that shot last
year small park only worked a couple
days but sweetheart of a guy and he sent
me a link to this basically is an Apple
commercial and I'm not really sure where
it was shot maybe maybe Tokyo or
something like that but it was all shot
on an iPhone and that's amazing and it
looks unreal
it looks unreal I was watching it and I
think they might have I think they might
have had in an another lens I'm like I'm
like um what would you get a movement I
got the moment moment moment probably
had a moment and lens on there something
like that you know some sound equipment
and lights maybe but it's looks
fantastic looks like looks like you
could have shot it on a red yeah that's
that's the crazy thing cuz this too
like just having this like moment lens
on this because I do all my stories with
this as well just because I'd like a bit
more things in the scene and so when I
do my interest orient people always
write the like yes I go what dears are
you usually alright isn't that a DSLR
yes and literally be the lens on this
phone yeah and most people don't know to
when they buy equipment they have these
cut these gear junkies now where they
buy the most up-to-date camera all the
time they go oh this cameras better site
broke you don't even shoot [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] that's right like it doesn't matter
you have a better camera learn how to
use the equipment that you have like you
just said somebody shot a whole Apple
commercial on this phone yeah you would
have never known the difference unless
somebody told you that otherwise which
blows my mind it's right yeah there's
some there's no excuses no so what's up
what's up next for you I mean obviously
I'm completing talk much about narcos
but okay that's okay yeah I mean what's
up next for you after after all this um
well I'm I'm
I've been saying it for years but I'm
kind of really kind of making trying to
make it a thing this year that I'm gonna
direct my first movie oh yeah there's a
couple things that I want to direct and
was a couple TV shows that my buddies
and I are are are developing and writing
and I I'd love to get something sold you
know I'm all over the board of genres Oh
like um horror I definitely want to do
like a cool horror film you so you've
never directed anything yet nah I've
directed some shorts and I've kind of
like ghost directed I some other things
you know I'm not gonna say what movies
yeah stuff that but I've had a heavy
hand and like a lot of the creative
process and kind of guiding a guiding
hand and a lot of things but I'm
confident that I could and it's just
kind of it's kind of the next step and
I'm producing stuff now but I feel like
working with the actors and kind of like
painting painting the pictures and
making whatever is captured and through
the lens communicate to the audience
that what the story that I want to tell
them it's like directing is such a
daunting thing just watching my buddy
Justin direct the film mm-hmm I like I
felt bad for him
oh really because it was like well he
was he was eat I mean he wrote acted
directed and he was also producing it as
well see I couldn't produce it at the
same time like I could be a producer but
I couldn't be the producer I was like
hit seventeen hats no yeah that's you
know I understand I get it and you guys
got done what you got had to get done
but I think the next time is like
because you guys have but you guys have
experienced now you don't have to do all
those things oh yeah for sure
that's not how it is on the next time
but just watch just like the
responsibility of a director it's I mean
you're the head of every single
department you you have to make sure
that revisions right and you're checking
in on everybody it's like you're the
parent and everybody else is the kid and
it's like it's just watching it just
gave me anxiety oh yeah yeah I mean I
feel I feel I feel comfortable there I
mean you've acted in so many things now
too so I I feel like your vision is will
be really set when you know what China
my camera junkie too and I love working
on cameras and I and I
and I understand it and what I don't
understand like what that point you you
try to do your best you can to surround
yourself with people when I directed my
first short I I have no desire to mess
with paperwork the production that
producing side of it no desire yeah
touch the paperwork you know I don't
want to call call actors and tell them
what their call times are I don't want
to deal with any of that stuff I should
I don't want to I don't want to touch it
it's just not something I'm interested
in the creative production a part of it
the you know putting things together you
know getting people involved you know
pulling people into the project that's
stuff um that I like doing but getting
the big puzzle pieces
you know the paperwork and all the other
details stuff I'm not really interested
in like watch watching some of these
producers work with a micro budget like
the guy that worked on his name is James
II just to see how well he worked yes
pennies was insane some people are
really good at it yeah my friend Maria
came in I call this like you know I
don't want to produce this thing you
came in and like a day later she had a
binder full of things and stuff
organized I'm like I would have never
done that I would have winged it and a
good job on the next one cool man so the
next projects that you're gonna do is
you're gonna go into creating your own
content which is yeah man which is like
what stuff that you do is its kind of
really inspiring to me because it's you
know I feel like I you know when I edit
my own short films and I do little
little things here and there and I and I
see the stuff that you and your your
your colleagues do that just the the the
innovative edit cuts and you know the
creative stuff that you guys use like my
hand I was like I just don't I feel like
I'm behind I always feel like I'm behind
I feel like I'm behind because you guys
I'm sure you're much younger than I am
so you have that you've already had a
big head bigger head start than I did
cause I decided to start editing until
you know seven or eight years ago like
and I'm still very remedial medial at it
I can I can cut something together and
make it look okay but it's like there's
not gonna be anything creative it's not
gonna be any swirl ends and like push
yeah but most most people can't even do
what I do either though usually
somebody else a yeah like the the people
that kind of lasted on the space as long
as that as I have was because I hated I
wanted to know what I was hiring people
force yeah so number one I wanted to
speak their language and number two I
don't want to get taken advantage of
sure so you know when for example I
would have a couple of betters who would
come on and you know they're like USC
grads and editing or whatever and that's
great but I think they some people just
you don't find some people are just
[ __ ] so you know I would ask them to
get this done at a certain time like
hello it's gonna take away like no it's
not [ __ ] like I can do this tonight I
just want I don't want to do it so I'm
trying to pay you to do it right so yeah
I had to take you into my own hands to
learn how to do all this stuff which
took a lot longer but there was a lot of
the Internet's crazy yeah I do this
everything everything's there all the
tutorials are there again there's no
excuses yeah
there's no excuses it might take you a
little bit longer to do something might
take you a little bit longer to edit it
might take you a little bit longer to do
these other things figure out how to
track somebody and move something into a
point like especially if you're shooting
6 K with this black new black magic or
you for some reason you find an 8k
camera you you know there's no excuse
for not composing your shot right yeah
but if you needed to push in on
something there's so much information
there that you can you can figure it out
and most people just watch in 1080
anyway so yeah yeah you shoot something
at 4k it blow it up move it around you'd
be fine yeah for sure
like I love tech mean so great well amen
well that wraps up this Bell's the
fast hour was it an hour now the hour
already pretty amazing well where can
everybody find you
on Instagram Jessie John Garcia in and
I'm very rarely on Twitter but Jessie to
the G number two perfect yeah and they
can catch you on this SEC what is it the
the season of narcos in Mexico narcos
Mexico season two is it out yet yep it
came out February 13th
oh yeah it's out its out I would watch
either if you haven't seen narcos Mexico
I would encourage you to watch season 1
just look as it flows right into season
2 but if you don't feel like watching
season 1 do some sort of like thorough
recap like it's like that I'm sure
there's something on it a little better
yeah because a lot of stuff that goes on
that we do in season 2 that really has a
lot to do with what happened in season 1
perfect yeah
well guys you guys can catch the podcast
on every single audio platform out there
leave in the comments below
chat and chat with each other talk all
the other [ __ ] and we'll see y'all
next time are you face